we know uh how ten ten thousand ten of
thousand uh UK Ukrainian civilians and
soldiers have been victims of this
conflict of violence but on the other
side also 100
000 Russian soldiers
and and for me is our bodies that ended
up in uh in the war machine
uh many times sometimes also young lives
emulated on the altar of
all the new irons
and and this this is by the way uh
um how a systematic rear moment can take
place
yet it should be clear that weapons uh
weapons only serve uh
to die and to make people die
and and the point is uh why should we
accept death as the inevitable
inevitable solution uh to conflicts
uh a policy that doesn't save life
but rather demands death
as a necessary solution is a
necropolitics the politics of death
and it is a policy which denies its own
task
which renounces itself in favor of war
and violence
so how to stop the war with negotiations
with mediations and let me put a last
question why has Europe
not assumed a mediating role that means
peace negotiates negotiations this is
the point for me peace negotiations and
pacifism would be a very good idea
fortunately we cannot afford it
and I would say that
sending
weapons is the only way why I'm here
today
so that's the only reason
if not Western help with weapons I may
not sit here
my child may be dead for now if not
assistance from with weapons
we will we would be doomed
you know so that's just just the
opposite situation
we badly need assistance
military assistance from the West I
think that's quite simple that if if not
for the help
with weapons and with other military
assistance
that will that would be more torture
chambers it would be more people died in
Kiev Kiev wasn't circled but Kiev was
not occupied
that would be all over Ukraine you know
I I guess you see this maps that
appeared before before The Invasion
because that was by the way a long
attempts to uh to talk to Putin macron
talk to Putin but I didn't talk to Putin
everyone everyone talked to Putin no
results absolutely 28th of February we
have the invasion
that was a very long story that was
months before that
nothing happened I want to say to
Donatello that I think you're 15 right
and 100 wrong
I think that
um all wars are terrible but I think
that we need to make distinctions among
Wars I think that it is a primary moral
obligation
uh to defend oneself and one's family
and one's community and it is a primary
obligation moral obligation it is a duty
to defend the weak
and neither of these two things can be
done without power and sometimes without
force or violence
now that what you shake your head but
um I know of no circumstance in which a
power launched a war of aggression and
in the middle of it decided that they'd
made a moral mistake and went home
I think that
everything about pacifism goes against
everything we know about the history of
the human heart generally pacifism likes
to speak in a very high-minded lofty
tone of morality and moralism and so on
my own view is that pacifism unless the
entire world becomes pacifist tomorrow
morning
pacifism's consequences are actually
immoral my position is not the position
of
I am on the side of European people but
I'm also on the side of Russian people I
have I am against leadership against Lee
against leader who are not responsible
this is the point I don't think as
philosopher that that that
polymers that war comes first
and then peace is something that we
reach later I think and it is the the
big result of philosophers like Manuel
levinaus and after the schwa in the the
the the the the the the idea that the
that that peace is the the relationship
with the other we need their other and
we need today a policy of cohabitation
for the European peoples and Ukrainian
and Russians are European peoples and
this is for me the point let me just say
that the the one thing you will miss you
cannot make an equivalence between the
Russians and the ukrainians except in so
far as they're both dying and they're
both being killed what we've learned
with the Ukraine is that today we have
people able to risk their life for
freedom and it's very impressive it's
true in Ukraine it's true in Taiwan it's
true in Iran it's true in Venezuela in
Cuba in many places in the world and we
have in Europe and in the US
I believe to yes to to be able to
to be
able to reform our countries and to
support Freedom too and to make the
necessary changes because they are huge
to support freedom in the 21st century
so that's I believe the the big lesson
of of Ukraine and for the especially for
the European it's a tough lesson